madame au sol on a entendu tous ces
témoignages terribles mais votre
commission aussi permis a permis
d'établir des chiffres donc 150 mille
enfants qui ont été arrachés à leurs
familles et il ya aussi ces milliers
d'enfants qui sont disparus pendant
cette époque du pensionnat comment est
ce que c'est possible c'est ça c'est
justement l'histoire des écoles de
d'avoir des circonstances où les enfants
sont très loin de chez eux sans assez de
surveillance sont les moyens des
ressources financières pour que les gens
les enfants soient bien habillé bien
nourris et bien
enfin bien sûr vivien protégé alors ça
peut arriver tout seul chose dans les
circonstances comme ça et puis
effectivement c'est ça qui est arrivé
ou bien les enfants qui en crever des
épidémies comme le taux d'uc to lose qui
étaient très fréquents dans les écoles
bien les enfants qui ont qui sont morts
dans les faits parce que c'étaient des
bâtiments terrible ou bien d'autres les
pauvres qui sont qui essaient de se
sauver à tel point souffrait des abus et
puis soit ils se sont perdus dans la
brousse ou bien se sont noyées ou bien
même un cas où il y avait des petits
jeunes qui sont on les a retrouvé tout
seul les bras entouré les uns des autres
et gelé à mort s'est il y en aurait
jusqu'à 6000 qui aurait disparu qui
serait mort ça dépasse l'entendement
vous dites que c'est un génocide
culturel qui survenus dans ces
pensionnats
alors maintenant que ce rapport est
déposé qu'est ce qui doit être fait
qu'est ce qui doit changer
mais ce qui va changer c'est l'ignorance
du canada d'abord ça c'est la toute
première chose il faut que tous les
canadiens et canadiennes selon compte
qu'est ce qui s'est passé que on se
passe de notre ignorance collective qui
a permis qu'on se connaît si peu dans ce
pays là et ça il faut qu'il ya des
changements de curriculum et
la création du curriculum nouveau
approprié pour les écoles mais ça peut
aussi quand on change les choses dans la
domaine public donc ça passe par
l'éducation est ce que c'est le
gouvernement fédéral qui doit prendre le
leadership là dedans c'est tous niveaux
de gouvernance je pense bien d'abord
c'est les provinces maintenant qui
s'occupe de l'éducation de beaucoup
beaucoup d'autochtones parce qu'il ya
peu près 60% des autochtones maintenant
qu'ils restent dans les villes et non
pas sur les réserves mais aussi c'est
une question de fournir des ressources
appropriées aux réserves et ça c'est
tout à fait l'idée la responsabilité du
gouvernement fédéral et ojej abattons
aussi que les églises fassent ce qu'ils
peuvent
alors eux aussi on l'a fait de l'appel à
l'action qu ils fournissent tout
l'argent pour contribuer à la re
création et le vital isation des langues
une toute dernière question il nous
reste très peu de temps mais vous madame
oleson qu'est ce que vous retenez de
toutes ces années de tous ces
témoignages de tout ce que vous avez
vécu qui a été assez
une intense je vais faire adouber
refaire une réflexion à savoir qu'est ce
que je fais maintenant pour continuer
quand même avancé à faire ma part parce
que oui la commission ça va être fini
mais ma vie des citoyennes ça serait pas
finie alors moi aussi il faut pas que je
lâche mais là il ya une élection qui
s'en vient dans quelques mois vous avez
vraiment pas peur que tout ça tombe dans
l'oubli que ce soit oublié jusque
prochain jusqu'au prochain gouvernement
prochain parlement
si les survivants qui ont vécu des
choses horribles à ce point là puis se
remonter l'esprit à dire nous on a
l'espoir et on compte sur vous je pense
que cette année le reste à la société de
répondre en mesure pour débat en verre
travaillent ensemble pour trouver des
solutions qu'il faut alors je lâche pas
l'espoir je ne lâche pas très bien merci
beaucoup mal à -5 d'avoir été mal merci
un moment
non